he's incredible he leading the team in scoring
it's just incredible what he's been able to do
especially the way he plays he plays a game so
hard how effectively he can do it at his age
now here's Philip forsberg gets the first shot of
the way out of the way for the Predators and it's
held get no shot attempts up early easy one there
for Wedgewood so yo Parson is back in the lineup
and he will skate with Luke Evangelista and Tommy
Novak here's Evangelista with the puck now he'll
throw it far side handled there by woodwood
flung back to the net by Roman Yosi kelki so
crafty works it into the corner against another
veteran Luke Shen he and Tyson Barry had a very
good game together in Philadelphia they're out
there again for across and the shot by Yosi is
stopped by wendwood he's a guy that the league
now is starting to really take notice of that's
that's incredible another great story that why
Johnson's another young player he's a for but oh
here we go around the corner a kick save there
by Yosi on the former Predator Craig Smith boy
you don't even have to see who it is just the
way he strides you know it's Craig Smith Crazy
Legs as we used to call them now a chance for
the pator Yosi bursts up the ice Novak comes in
with him the shot towards the net save by WT
would put him in there end that play he just
completely killed that play by finishing his
check hits that mean something not just for
show Here Comes Dallas leli to the slot tipped
on net slowly and sorrow's tracked it now Jason
Robertson such a dangerous player pavelsky shot
is stopped by Soros here's a twisting pass from
hin same action there and that Got Away paron
sees an opportunity brings it in fees it to
the wing the shot is gloved down by Wedgewood
got to know those Tendencies pretty well time
this one kicks out in front of the deflection
suda right down the middle save made rebound
Robertson got the shot away a save made by Soros
p deore and his his system last year dominated
the Predators four wins a combined score of 17
to5 only one of the games was even close hsur
anticipated the pass shouldered off the puck
by Robertson O'Reilly makes the feed right
down the middle Cole Smith charging to the net
save by Falling wedw picked up again in Center
flect it up in the air Barry jumps on it good
scoring chance Cole Smith again getting behind
the defense he's done that so often this year
yeah that was a beautiful pass by O'Reilly now
Barry fading back makes the pass deflected out of
the air nist to the side of the net O'Reilly out
to the point Barry to the net save Wedgewood
rebound loose three and a half to go in the
first go handed that for sure would put a body
on the youngster Harley now down low pass out
to the slot the shot great save by Soros rebound
loose another stop and Yosi snared it he saved
the goal a glose save by Yosi s's down and all
look at Yosi scramble City Yosi goes oh and he
gets the glove on it he throws it out of the way
are you kidding me 38 seconds to go hinan breaks
out back the other way got away from marman sent
up the Wing by lazan attacking sistens with Smith
Co Smith turns to his forehead save by Wedgwood
talk about another player with confidence right
now he's getting the point totals watch this
quick hands just pulls it in he kind of kind
of fakes hinan like he's going to go wide
pulls it back hinan thought Hook Line and
Sinker here's keeper Sherwood tried to make a
tight quarter pass to thomasino who chases it
good keep in Thomas got an open man mcdunn
winds up hammers one trick to the clock hit
in WW made the B it popped up behind
him and just enough distance to get
across keeper Sherwood you want to talk
about going to the net hard watch and
learn they're Sherwood first one in on the
four check makes contact and I don't know
but it hits shwood it hits Michael McCarron
but it definitely hits the traffic in front
and then he goes down and swipes it in
what a play here there's McCarron there's
shwood as he went down f there but opportunity
here PR PP first one of the game for the
Predators here's porb on the attack out to
the high slide around the cour quick low high
score it's col siss great Puck movement off of
the face off and the Predators have taking a two
nothing lead and this is what you call excellence
in execution right here watch the movement and
look how everybody opens up right there down
low it's a gus nist here Factor goes to nist
assistance right in the slot Wedgewood makes a
nice save he stays there he gets a rebound right
back on his stick and then Glides it into the
empty net as Wedgewood got it across the line
Tracked Down by McCarron even when the the stars
get in there and they're pressuring the PRS oh oh
great pass ahead here they come save by Soros matu
Shane tried to flip it and float it and buying it
watch this fights off Barry lifts it sorrow stands
up watches it right into the glove Duan just stops
him on in his tracks that was beautiful he didn't
bite he just stood there right in the middle of
the chest and bumped Duan off the Pucket lead
over to the wian puts it right in front it's
still loose and pouncing on it is Soros right
at the hor in the third period sud back to grab
long stretch past to Marksman at the end of a
long Chip he hits the trailer open man Smith
he hit the post likes to get the long passes
he sneaks down there knows how to do it on the
trail hints shot blocked by Barry a big one hints
again there come the Stars Tic Tac Toe in front
score the initial pass was deflected right back
to Genny danov who scores the first goal of the
game and the stars are right back in it it
allows Soros to open up a little bit so quick
shot here I don't know if it hits Barry good
job by Barry there breaking that one up watch
this going to come right over there slows down
it ends up who's in the high neutral in the high
slot rate here lindel sneaks down puts it right
back on D donov and then Saros unable to close
all the holes there on that play that goes
back to another big hit perfectly timed he
got steel that time now leveraging low trying to
Wi for puus NIS he chips it ahead racing forward
forsburg forsberg will get there forsberg hit
the post burn back by the Stars bouncing pluck
inside the line cig Smith hustling play to get it
to Robertson looks to the net front tip just wide
mcdunn can't secure it it's loose to the side
of the net s towards the net they score C Smith
ties the game 13 seconds on the clock it looked
like the Predator's maze tried to guide it back
to Soros but that's neither here nor there they
don't get that and this is seconds later that's
that puck right there see mcdunn gets hooked
he gets hooked Coming Around the Net believe
that's Robertson who is eventual Craig Smith
is eventual goal score but yeah right there
it goes it just bounces off nist I don't think he
meant to put it back to SOS but that does create
that comes in and puts it upstairs or of all
people Craig Smith with a huge goal just his
third of the year now this one losing the slot
still 5 Seconds To Go hocky P shot they score
unbelievable the stars have turned the game
around a goal with 13 seconds Yanni Haw andpa
just blasts this one as they keep this Play
Alive it hits Sam steel doesn't get up and
it gets through you Saros there's a sea
of gold right in the middle I don't know
if he sees this or if it gets deflected on
the way doesn't see it it gets under Soros
and Nashville with 13 seconds away from
winning the game in regulation and the
Stars just Rob the Predators cig Smith
followed up by the shot from hackin paa